ever build a mosque for Allah Allah will
build for him a similar house in Jenna
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale these are two very large men I
think we're going to see some lightning
connect here don't blink ladies and
gentlemen off they go Mohammad hijab
versus re
here hijab starts off with hij
jaab onew combination leg kick oh brutal
leg kick there
Reese replies with the leg kick of
himself I think Reese was attempted a
take down
there solid leg kick that hit the bone
snapping bone on
bone Reese looking to throw these big
overhands that typical style you'd like
to see kind of a heavyweight boxer just
big overhand right tell you that hijab
trying to slow down with those leg kicks
beautiful left hook there Reese went for
the overhand he knows he's a big man he
has to throw the over but be the style B
yeah you see I'm sure gu's looking to
get in but hijab has done a beautiful
job here of just keep the distance with
those leg
kicks that punch just missed by inches
both guys having fun here it'll be
interesting to see if we slows down with
those leg kicks they clearly affected
him cuz he's
limping doing a great
job those leg kicks are C
damage you went to you went to go low
and went High did
hijab I think I like see hijab like
faint the low kick but come High re's
hands are very low I'd like to see hijab
us his reach cuz he's throwing a jab but
they just AR punches he needs to snap
them out and step into the
jab CU he's clearly got the reach
Advantage yeah I think like a lot of
fight especially debut they're kind of
feeling out but I'd like to see that Jab
use a bit of a yard stick measure
distance to set those bigger shots or
his
takedowns I mean at the moment Ben this
just seems like a stand up K1 bout you
know these guys needs to mix it up I'm
sure the quarterman will say listen guys
let's get some takedowns I mean we saw
re having half a of a taked down but he
probably thought he's a big guy I don't
know if I want to take him
down think you see that a lot in the
heavyweight division guys don't really
want to risk the Tak down cuz a lot of
weight to be spred on top of you if you
make a poor shot very true
that again hij needs to keep those hands
up because there's a few times that re
swung for the fences and one connection
could be the end of
it big hook there by
Reese yeah ree definitely finding is
kind of comfort zone here he's getting
the field but as he's getting more tight
those hands are dropping and someone as
big as hijab something
connects striking was I mean hijab you
know he's kept it tight you know he's
snapping it out he just needs to step
into it a little bit more I think as
well like those Jabs whether they
connect or not follow them up with
another jab or a right
hand the first
round having
obviously whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jenna and we know the great
reward that will not only be gained but
rather will fill your grave after your
death whenever someone prays there
whenever someone gives shahada in the
Masid whenever someone learns something
in the Masid yes that will be something
that you'll have on your
scale people have been stopped by leg I
mean Jose Aldo a prime example look Jose
Alo your fa fa man the wec days that
before the UFC had the lightweight
classes and I'll tell you
something ree here is going to feel both
leg kicks tomorrow 100% I think like
you're right with it affecting his
balance like hij might connect it might
not actually drop him but his balance is
gone it could send him backwards and a
bit of ground and pound on the back end
of that it could all be over so I mean
right there before there you go to
take I could I could just
pri's going to work with the ground
pound he's punching blind he needs to
posture up and look where he's hitting
cuz ree is actually blocking those shots
you know he's not in trouble ree hold it
yeah that's it hold it hold it hold it
hold
it so ree doing a good job here of
keeping the posture of hijab broken I'd
like to see hijab try and posture up to
land some shots but again that's all lot
of man to try and posture up yeah and I
tell you what I would not want to be
under right now I mean he a mountain of
a man 6' 7 in tall you know almost 12
kilo that's a lot of weight to have on
you especially if there's base there as
well yeah whether it's in a like Reese
looks safe here but it's kind of one of
those ones it's still going to tax him
here he's few shots to the
body that's what hij needs to do he's
softening the body up used to go through
the body and head as the corner is
screaming out stand
up I mean that shoulder pressure is
going to be suffocated as it is isn't
[Music]
it yeah a lot of adrenaline a lot of
heat in that cage and with another man
smothering you you're going to start to
kind of panic you're getting tired the
the same arm which hijab is using to
soften the body
up Reese's shoulders block in his head
anyway so he's he's going to have to go
the long way around and excuse me see
Shar screaming the instructions out to
the body and to the head and that's
exactly what mhamad to do the referee is
basically resetting them back in the
center of the cage in the same position
I would have actually liked to see the
referee stand them up there because
wasn't much action happening was there
Ben I don't think the space was the
issue I think it was just the position
okay
so like I think resetting this position
we're not going to see that much more
action I think standing the back up with
in the right cor there not resetting
them back in the middle in this
position I mean he's resting as well
he's comfortable there he knows it he
needs to get his forearm create some
space and go for the ground and cuz he's
got there you go he's doing exactly he's
got all big
elbow again re straight back into
controlling the
head yeah I don't think that one elbow
did much damage there Tes I mean look he
may not have the advantage on the ground
but he's he's a fighter he's been in the
ring or the cage 50 times you know
that's just shows how he
is so we got think here that that round
who ever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jenna and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your
scale everyone's got a punch his chance
especially both these guys so big
throwing some power behind their shots
something connects it could be done hij
he's using his lead hand there to keep r
b to gauge the distance and he started
off doing that in the last round and
caught the kick so I think he's going to
look for that take down again but it's
it's the case of if reys will be smart
enough to realize that that's what he's
trying to do it's nicely Reese moving a
little more he's circling away he's
moving
around again you heard that from the
crowd there you know is so dangerous
that punch and he's a heavyweight so
that connects it lights out
[Music]
[Applause]
again that's a lot of leg to be Ted with
so that's the end of the
fight body shot yeah kick to the St up
area mamed hij takes the win as the main
event on half
challenge again we were talking earlier
with with uh shb about how bad a body
shot can be and it's like you saw there
it landed re kind of took a second and
was like no but it's done yeah I mean it
was to the midsection and if you've been
TI to that region before you know how
that feels and when you got someone like
Mohamed hijab who 6' seven in tiing you
the stomach you're going to go down yeah
I think as well going into that third
round you're tired already you're
breathing heavy that shot lands on an in
breath and next thing you know you're
struggling to breathe very fast
well what a great main event that was
pul fight in on Omar combat the third
show and it just gets better and better
better and tell you the crowd of being
in for
[Music]
tree basically um
TKO
TKO the M
with
t wrap this up and make official but one
great return for you MMA the cage please
[Music]
ladies and
gentlemen and your winner by way of TKO
Muhammad
[Applause]
hijab well what a great FR to a great
evening Muhammad hij victorious in his
Pro MMA
debut um yeah you know he's is it going
to be going back to the gym and working
on things and coming back and getting
stronger we're going to wait and see yes
and again fantastic show from four four
dates set for next year so kind of we're
on the UPS potentially we can see
Muhammad hijab back in the Uma cage
returning kind of working on some skills
and see kind of muhamad hijab 2.0%
Muhammad pick couple of words amazing
support first and foremost for you
absolutely first I want to say
ald that you did not throw when you
threw but it's Allah who threw so
everything that happens to me in
goodness belongs to Allah subhana I also
want to thank every single one of my
coaches the head coach Stuart Austin
who's done a phenomenal job at fight
Zone to get a history teacher like me to
get into the ring and to win in the way
in a spectacular fashion that I did
number one number two I want to thank
fight Zone and Roger graci Academy and
Big H and uh uh Rowan and everybody
everybody who's contributed to this
success um and I want to thank all of
you and uh and you know this couldn't
have been done without the will of Allah
and when you believe in the and the will
of Allah everything is possible
why MMA MMA is a way to empower people
we have seen people all over the world
being hurt we're seeing them being
injured and there's no way out of that
except to develop the fundamental virtue
which even Aristotelian philosophers
including Aristotle himself consider to
be Chief most of importance which is
bravery itself bravery is the most
important thing to develop and you can't
develop bravery as a muscle if you just
talk about it theoretically MMA for me
is one of the best and ultimate ways to
prove bravery on a physical level and
that's why I think it's very important
to do it one more question for me
Muhammad how did this Victory compare to
your Rich against Pierce Morgan on that
debate I tell you what I tell you the
truth this victory was more for my own
personal growth and for the Muslim
people but that one was for calls
directly that one was I considered to be
an act of worship so anything that is
considered to be an act of worship for
me is always more dear to me than the
things that I do in my past time I have
to be honest but having said that there
is one weasel who has been running away
and this is probably the first time in
my history this happened but you know as
you know I'm a debater as well right I
want to challenge somebody and it's not
who you think it is it's not a fighter
it's it's not you my friend don't worry
it's bapiro
yes you're a coward chiro you've been
running away I don't expect you to fight
like us the people of the resistance and
the people that fight against the I
don't expect you to do anything like
that but Ben Shapiro you've been running
away I expect you to at least defend
your indefensible position or at least
attempt to defend that position on the
mutual ground maybe it could be p
morgage on sensed who knows maybe you
made four maybe maybe in a cage with one
of our lightweights but I think any of
the lightweights he would have a panic
attack before he came and tried to fight
one of those guys so it would have to be
like that I don't think he has the
testicular
fortitude what's
next what's next what's next is I'm
going to do more of these with this
wonderful gentleman ay who has headed
this promotion done an excellent job I
have to him he's done an excellent
job brilliant
job we've got more fights to come you
know and of course the father mallah
thank you so much for everything as well
I appreciate you and the kids and
everybody that's come out today
wonderful wonderful wonderful job and I
hope to see you guys here in wonderful
cry next
time thank you very much br
great job very thank you very
much can all staff make their way into
the cage please all staff and security
made way into the cage for the rest
of really appreciate the sport look
forward to see you
next once again security and staff
please make your way into the cage all
security and St
official
all Security in the stage um security
and stuff into the cage please
B
the